scientists have found evidence of liquid
water on Mars see the dark brown streaks
running down the slopes of the Red
Planet's hail crater they're salty
tracks like tear stains that confirm
there is indeed water on Mars and that
it is flowing scientists have long known
there is ice on Mars but these stains
are mineralogical evidence that water
dribbles down the planets steep slopes
using data collected by NASA's Mars
Reconnaissance Orbiter scientists have
been following these salty tracks which
Evan flow during cooler and warmer
temperatures they haven't actually seen
any water but the mineral traces show
evidence of water molecules mixed into
their crystal structures we don't know
where exactly the water comes from it
might come out of Mars's atmosphere or
it could be melting and percolating out
of the planet's frozen surface or even
bubbling up from an aquifer whatever the
reason it's evidence that Mars could
support life possibly even human life if
we figure out how to colonize the place
you